Hello, everyone. Thank you for joining us today.
Today, I have the pleasure of having Alex
Ellis join me so that we can do
a walk through of the OpenFaaS repositories by
analyzing the commits with a tool that I've
been working on called git series,
in which we load all of the commits
and the deltas within the commits into influx
DB to see what we can learn.
First, hello, Alex. How are you?
Hello, David. Good to see you.
I think I've heard you talking about the
Git series program a few times,
and was sort of interested when you reached
out to find out a bit more about
what your tool is doing and how you
put it together.
And maybe I can give a bit of
flavor
to what you're seeing and a bit more
context.
So, yeah, I'm interested to see what we
can get to.
Yeah. So this was conference driven development. I
submitted
a talk called get lost in time series
to try and showcase
new novel use cases for time series that
goes beyond the basics, Linux system monitoring. Like,
we all we've all done it. We all
know how to do that, but I wanted
to try and find something different. And the
top got accepted and I went, oh, shit.
I need to write this tool now.
And that's what we'll show. So
let's get up to speed.
I will share
my screen.
Just yeah. Can you see my dashboard?
Yeah. I can see it. Awesome. Alright. So
this is a tool that is hosted on
GitLab
and written in Go.
The funny story is there is another version
written in Rust.
So we have getthat.com/Rawkode/getseries,
which is the Rust version.
I had a few challenges with that other
than my own inability to write good Rust
codes, which is getting better all the time.
But the let get library for Rust was
single threaded to no concurrency and then support
async await. So processing slightly larger repositories
proved to be quite cumbersome.
So I fell back to the my more
familiar tooling, which was go and rewrote the
tool here. You're more than welcome to to
compare this, run it yourself on your own
repositories and have some fun. Just noticed you
don't have a read me in this in
this version.
But in the rest one, it seemed like
you run the tool and then you pipe
it to influx right.
That is correct. Effectively doing a generating insert
statements.
Very similar. So, yeah, you point us at
a repository, you give it the analyze command,
and you can it's best out raw line
protocol, which is like the
it's just the raw format that influx to
be understands for rate endpoints without doing any
conversion.
Okay. And then just take that to influx
rate
or
there is an example report What's that look
like? It's a line.
Yeah.
Oh, here's some I prepared earlier. Oh, no.
It's not there. I'll share
my whole screen this time, which k. Never
goes wrong. Right? So so
this is my CloudVM
where I processed all of the OpenFaaS
line protocol. Now if I just check one
that's small
The name would be small. The Cloud Functions
one will be pretty small. Alright. Let's go
for the Cloud Functions
then
oh,
let's
yeah. I think I suppose as big as
I can get it, but it said it's
going too legible. But this is a lane
of lane protocol.
It essentially starts with a metric or measurement
name.
So this is actually analyzing one of the
lines. This is one of the deltas where
they get history.
It then applies a bunch of tags which
allow us to slice and dice this data
at query time.
So you can see here, we have a
fair amount
of tags.
So when we analyze a line from the
ref log, we
add a host, an owner, and a repository,
which allows us to identify where the change
came from.
Right. We added from GitLab, for instance, it
would be
a different host.
Yeah. Exactly. So this is GitHub OpenFaaS cloud
functions dot Git.
We have a status annotation a tag on
a line changes, which tells whether the line
was added or deleted,
the directory in which the change occurred,
the file name, the extension is then broken
down just because we wanna be able to
create it up on its own. We have
the author name, the author email,
and whether I was able to detect a
comment marker
as really crude code if you look at
it, I'm basically looking for a hash symbol
or a double slash
or a slash star, I think.
So it's not sophisticated, but it will hopefully
give us a little bit of insight into
when documentation was added to the project or
whether the project started with documentation.
Good for identifying,
you know, hackathons generally produce a lot of
documentation for projects you can see. Contents
there. That must be quite a burden on
the database to import all the contents of
every delta.
Like, we've got the exact type of change,
right, on each line. Well, yeah. So the
reason I add the contents is really because
I like to filter projects commits for swear
words and then see how much they swear.
But this space here means that it's no
longer a tag and this is stored as
a field. So it's not indexed. So searching
is much slower. Yeah. You couldn't index that
really. But what you could do is something
I did at my at university actually is
I wrote a
a tool that would basically do a bit
of
something called, like, t TDIF.
I don't know the exact terminology now, but
you could you could find the density of
terms relative to the catalog.
You could add the most interesting ones.
I don't know. Can you do a kind
of
array,
or does it just have to be comment
value?
Yeah. And, of course, d b fields only
store a string or integer or numeric types.
Okay. No worries.
Mhmm.
And have you got the commit message here?
Yes.
So
because this is the line, we won't see
it there, but it'll be great on commit.
Actually, just above there's a word that says
commit.
Yeah. So because this is a VM, I
I can't seem to clear anything or at
least maybe this is just a Google Cloud
thing, but let's just try and highlight this.
So we do have a commit here. So
the tags are very similar. We have the
author where it came from.
The fields are slightly different. We now have
how many files are modified in this commit.
We have the total sum of insertions and
deletions.
We do store the sha as well so
that we can then do something with that
commit if we choose to, and we have
the commit message here.
That's great. So you got lines,
and that's one series. You've got commit. That's
another series. Have you got anything else that
you'd do?
Yes.
But why don't we browse that from here?
So let's leave the dashboard for the time
being.
We'll come to the data explorer,
which is gonna be a bit nicer than
just looking at the line protocol itself.
When did the OpenFaaS when was first commit?
You could put you could put 2016.
'20 '16.
Yeah.
Alright. So this is the measurements that we
have. So we see in the line.
We've seen commit. We also have tags so
that we can track the releases that were
tagged with the repository.
And we do some interesting
stuff with the file itself. So we we
track when a fail was added and removed
from the repository,
breaking that down by extension to try and
identify what kind of code
has come and gone with the
repository.
What I found really interesting when I was
processing the influx DB report itself is you
can actually visualize that transition from JavaScript to
TypeScript
because the JavaScript code has this big line
gone up, and then TypeScript comes up and
JavaScript falls off a cliff. So Interesting.
So I'm I'm seeing the
the the sort of outer
part of this, the database to call it,
the git series, and then I'm seeing a
number of measurements, but I don't see the
extension as a field for that measurement
in your view now.
Yes. Because that is a tag. So we
filter looking at a specific field. Okay. So
we can browse on there. We can have
access flex
the UI
for a long time. It seems to have
changed
the redesign.
Yes. So today, we are running the two
point o beta release.
This new shiny allows us to play with
the new query language, which is functional. So
if I show you that let's see.
Let's just look at the last thirty days
of files and hit submit. We can view
the raw data,
And we can see that we have the
author,
the directory that's failed existing.
As we spoke about just before we went
live, we're gonna see a lot of those
vendor directory.
And
we can exclude on that as well, right,
because we know where it is. We we
can exclude. Yeah. Because that's the tag, we
can try and use the regex filter to
say, don't show me anything within the vendor.
And
whether the fail was modified or whether it
was new. And you have PromQL as well,
don't you? So I remember there was a
big sort of controversy about influx and Prometheus
and then Influx went and implemented the PromQL
language. Is that still available?
So there's a transpiler,
which is in its
early days. It's not something that is n
two point x at this point in time.
Okay. But the PromQL transpiler,
the plan being you can use PromQL to
transpile to flux, which is the language that
we see here.
Right. Okay. That's interesting.
And Julius from the Prometheus team has been
working on that for influx.
Yeah. It's quite exciting.
I haven't followed the status of it in
the last month or so, but hopefully, it's
still coming along pretty well.
Okay.
Now this isn't the sequel that I'm used
to seeing all the No. In fact, q
l was the query language from influx d
b one. Because we're using influx d b
two, we're using the new shiny
functional
Mhmm. Flux language.
Can I can I go back and use
what I know or do I just have
to figure this out?
You will be able to soon. So there
is a current work in progress right now
within influx data to provide influx q l
compatibility mode for people who want to continue
using that SQL like language.
Cool.
Okay. So we kind of discussed get series
as a tool.
I've shown you the output.
I use telegraph to import that to influx
d b. The example is on get series
dash example,
where you can see the Telegraph configuration and
a dark compose file for spinning up influx
d b two.
The only other thing that I have done
before we started streaming today was apply this
packager dot yamo. So and in flux d
b two also supports a manifest format very
similar to Kubernetes.
This allows us to create the buckets, create
variables,
and create dashboards. Everything that we're gonna look
at today was applied from this massive 1,800
lines of YAML.
So
what that what that gave us was How
do find writing those files? I mean, is
that something that I can generate once I've
keyed it in in the UI, or do
I need to write it there and then
keep applying it until the UI looks as
I want it?
Yes. You can definitely use the UI, and
then you can export
any of the dashboards individually from here. Or
using the CLI tool, you can export everything
from your instance, and it will give you
the YAML file there. And what did you
do for yours? Because it's quite long, isn't
it? It's quite a few bits and pieces
in there.
Yes. I I built in the UI and
I export to YAML. Although,
I am rather active right now
on influx DB just in it.
Yeah.
That will make things
a bit more programmatic.
So I've been working on this for a
good couple of months now. It's got decent
support. There are a few things that I
still need to improve in it
Mhmm. To support more of the types. And
I kinda I took a step back a
little bit just because the influx d b
to package our component
was just starting to approach being generally available.
So now that that is my plan is
to go back and complete those bindings for
JSON. JSON at JSON. I don't know which
one is prepared.
Nice.
Alright. So let's take a look at the
first dashboard then. So we have four available
to us today. It's the overview, which is
gonna allow us to take a high level
look at all of the OpenFaaS repositories that
I imported. We'll then kinda do a deep
dive into one or two of the more
interesting ones using your judgment there.
The last two dashboards
are very much a work in progress. I'm
curious to see what we get out of
them. But that's one here, the year on
year,
tries to show you
just like a side by side comparison of
each year that the project has been active.
And the wall of shame, which is really
poorly named, and I apologize. But it tries
to just do something a bit more fun
with the data. So
for open source, I don't think it's gonna
be that useful. But if you run this
on a private repository within an organization,
it'll give you interesting stats, like, needs time
off, who's been committing more than four days
a week for three
months or something like that. So Boom. It
try it tries to build, like, leaderboards and
and
Alright. I'd be able to see that.
Alright. So we'll start with the overview.
Let me move this out of way.
Cool.
So you said 2016.
Let's just push this back a little bit
and try and find that first commit.
First commit should be right at the end.
It is.
So That's really
December. Yeah.
Yep. We got 19 commits before the 01/01/2017.
So this was a Christmas hobby project then
that
spiraling out of control. No. It started before
that, actually.
It was called
dis dispatch, phone call dispatch, and it was
a Node. Js application I'd written,
publicized. It got really popular. But then I
decided to rewrite it in Go and submit
it as a docker phone call hack.
And so I think about November, I had
the code on my computer. I pushed it
up in in December then.
Just carried on as you see it quite
regularly from then.
Nice.
So are we gonna see that JavaScript nodes
transition, or was that essentially Maybe that was
a different that was in a different place.
That was right one, throw it away.
We can find that repo later, but it's
not in the OpenFaaS org. Okay. No problem.
What will we see? I guess at some
point, when we do if we delete the
vendor folder in the Go code, we'll see
the code base get a lot a lot
smaller
at some point,
but not just yet.
Yeah. Yeah. I think we we definitely we'll
try and filter that out when we get
down to the the weeds of things for
sure. Now the first thing that's jumping out
to me are these peaks at Christmas
each year. Do
you tend to do a lot of coding
over the I have to do it a
bit slower
so that I can see I can't read
it when you move the mouse that fast.
Oh, sorry. That's that's October then. That's not
So we got yeah. It's just before, like,
the progressive break. And here we have November.
So October, November seems to be where you
find your stride.
Well, it's probably related to things that were
going on there. And as we say with
the rendering,
it that could just be that someone added
a dependency that had a lot of code
there.
It might not necessarily be what it looks
like. So perhaps
there was something that we added in the
Kubernetes client.
So this is just the number of commits
we're looking at just now? So is it
kind of k. So that commits rather than
the lines. In which case, yeah, then
the vendor folder wouldn't come into that.
No. So this is a pull everything out
of get series over a dashboard time range.
We're gonna filter the measurements on the commits.
We're pulling on the message just because we
need some field to count.
We flatten the table structure, which we can
talk about if we wanna get into how
flux works, but we flatten it and then
we do an aggregation over a window. So
we're breaking down
the commits into monthly chunks, and we do
account of those commits within that window. I
mean, I suppose the first thing that you
see there is that
at some point,
the first before the first peak, when was
that?
Sorry. The first big peak. I go back
to the beginning of the curve at the
bottom.
Where are we at? We're
that's interesting.
We we're after the first DockerCon where I
presented this
in Austin, Texas,
and we already moved over to having a
Kubernetes provider. We go back a bit further
till we get to about April.
I think it was April, May was when
that presentation was. It was just after that
that
I decided we needed Kubernetes support in OpenFaaS.
You can see how early on it was
in the lifespan it was put in.
And then the FaaS CLI came about after
that, which is potentially
why we've got that. That's, like, the third
blob.
The community
started contributing more then as well.
Have we got a breakdown of total contributors?
We do. Two two cells down from here.
So we'll get to there in just a
moment. Can you bring it up perhaps and
show a Nick that what we might see
is you should correlate it.
But they they come inside.
I mean, that doesn't look right either because
there's
hundreds of contributors. And if this is the
whole
history, that didn't look right.
So there's 372
contributors across the entire time. But are correct?
Do I have 284
on our metrics?
Alright. Let me refresh this dashboard.
Jump back down. If it is some discrepancy
there.
Let's see what this query is doing. So
we pull out
all of the commits.
Now it depends on
the
merge process for these projects because if you
use merge commits, I may have to remove
the filtering out basis. But remove it anyway,
see what happens. Yeah. So we do it
unique on the author email.
Okay. Let's submit this.
Still doesn't still looks very low.
Is
it a commit you're looking for? I mean,
we do rebases on it.
Okay.
Let let's debug. Right? I'm gonna copy this.
And the author email, as I saw in
your previous query, was mine for all of
them. So I think what you might need
is a committer email or you might need
another field there,
which might be where it's going wrong.
What other columns have you got?
Let's go back to our data explorer and
try and work this out. I saw Lucas
last commits into FASD.
If you look at the last thirty days,
maybe there'll be there was some data there.
Pull this all out. We'll just look at
commits, and I wanna grip by
oh,
I've angered it. There we go.
Let's just write it in flux.
We want to group by
column,
author,
email.
Yeah. That's the problem. It's that that you're
effectively using the wrong field. I think you
need to use author name
because when it's rebased, it's not
oh, we got an error.
What's going on here?
These are all of the commit objects.
We have author name and email there. Oh,
Dan and author name. I'm pretty sure I
saw Lucas in there recently.
Yeah.
Ken.
But
the email isn't changing.
So what you need to do is
because of the way it's rebased I had
this one. I was working with the Git
API because Derek,
our bot, can generate very detailed release notes
and the specific fields you need to pull
out
to get back to the original email.
So if you were able to use author
name instead, I don't know why your group
command
isn't working. It should be better.
Well, I think that's an
we've got a schema collision.
So I think one of the author names
is
a float value.
Interesting.
What about put a where in there? Could
you put a where where it's a string?
Is one of them a null maybe?
I'm not sure how to handle this just
now. Let's
come back in here and see if we
can modify it on our graph.
So
configure,
and I'm just gonna change this.
Alright. That may be better then. Looks better.
Looks closer.
Okay. Now you see that big peak there?
I think if you somehow able to pull
that graph up to underneath the commits, we
might see them correlate.
Sorry. What were you what were you suggesting
there? Put the contributors
graph
up,
drop it underneath the commits once we can
see them together.
So imagine you can do that. So just
yeah. If you plunk it.
Did I not drag it? Let's try again.
Alright. Come with me.
There
we go.
And over here.
Yep. So
So that I think that's kind of indicative
of what happened in the project as well
as well as those peaks, which is that
more people, more commits.
After the DockerCon event, we went and added
the Kubernetes support more or less on my
own, but then we create a CLI.
And there might be a way that you
can add to this graph what repo it
is so we can project it by
how many contributions and what repo they were
a member of. I don't know if you
can do that.
So we do break it down here. So
let's first get rid of this colon, and
then we will update the queries
so that they're all using the author name
so that we don't have any
weirdness.
And then you've got a reference to offer
email above that to remove.
I don't know if you wanna remove that.
We'll just we'll keep the gap stuff in
unless we noticed a problem.
So
what we can see here is
the contributions
were in FaaS
CLI and FaaS
Well, FaaS CLI came about at that point
because at DockerCon when I showed this off,
there wasn't a CLI. So it was bash
files that built the OpenFaaS containers. Now we've
got FastCLI build and FastCLI up.
And then we have Fastnetis,
the first submit
really early. So what's that? August 2017?
Yeah. Okay. So it late it was open
sourced or put on online later than I
thought. I thought it was just after that
DockerCon.
Obviously, it was a little bit later.
And then that one
it's quite interesting to see that one spikes
that's being developed.
Yeah. Definitely. We had a lot of traction
around blog posts and events of people going
out and doing that. So we've got more
people contributing to the FaaS repo,
that number going up.
Yeah. And and what's the FaaS provider that
kicked off around the same time? Yeah. So
that was to support the
the work for Fasenetis so that
it was effectively
hardcoded to to Swarm.
At that point, introduced a REST API, HTTP
REST API,
and Fast Provider became the like a a
standard, and then Fastenetis implemented it.
And that later, FastWarm
got broken out of FaaS, and then it
implements that as well.
And
do you know off the top of your
head before I I hover, but what's this
big orange peak?
Where are you?
Just at the end of twenty eighteen, the
orange peak. Your mouse isn't
where you think it is. Well, if I
hover over it, it'll tell you what the
repo is. I was trying not to.
Okay. You mean that massive one there?
That is probably the workshop.
If it's not the workshop, it might be
OpenFaaS cloud.
It was OpenFaaS cloud. Yeah.
So that kicked off when We can find
out when the workshop was created on here
as well.
And I think it was some way in
2018 because I did it with my team
at VMware.
I didn't import the workshop.
We didn't. No. Sorry.
But do you see FaaS swarm is in
there? And if you can single one out,
I don't know if you can filter one
out. Look at FaaS swarm,
you see basically almost
never changes in history and that's because
the API has been super stable.
Yep. Even when it was being actively hacked
on by doc the Docker team, it was
not
a pain to work with compared to Kubernetes
go client.
So we can filter out here, but we
could also do the deeper dive on the
next dashboard too.
So FaaS
swarm like that? Yeah.
No.
I'm not sure I've got this right. Is
that task net is
task d.
Yeah. You've got something wrong in your query.
I definitely have something wrong in my query.
Let's just drop this back out.
Submit.
And then we'll use this wonderful raw data.
And we can see oh, it's dot dot
get on the end. Okay. Got it. Yeah.
So that's warm dot get.
That's better.
Nice. There's there's swaddswarm.
And even though there's a peak there,
I guess we're not really looking at the
commits now. We're looking at the the amount
of contributors, but
it's pretty flat.
Yeah. I guess, I mean, Kubernetes
just took over then, especially over the last
eighteen months. I'm curious about these little
They're just sort of tweaks, maybe for the
documentation,
updating the Golang version.
It's not being deprecated yet.
What
is the wavy one in the background? That's
the FaaS, isn't it?
The the pink wavy?
Yeah. Yep. That's FaaS.
Where's FaaS d come in?
Let me find that. It'd be in the
last sort of it'd be in 2019,
I think.
Let's just I thought the color of it
there.
So there is a change in the master
branch of influx DB that allows you to
change how these tooltips work. So you can
filter on an individual series, but it's not
on the dock. I'm legit.
I added that feature because I got really
frustrated with to get series analysis. Mhmm.
Because there's a lot of series, and I
wanna be able to pick how I interact
with it. So you want to take a
look at FaaS d. Right?
There we go.
Oh. First
just me just show you then. Oh, actually,
you know, the thing about this is is
that it's more complicated than that because it
was in my account
and it was called FaaS container d.
So, again, this is why context is is
everything really,
is it started a lot earlier as fast
container d, and then at some point,
I created FASD and then decided they both
needed to live together,
and that isn't reflected.
Yeah. That's So it wasn't the renamed repo.
It was You can share all this this
context now, which is great. Yeah.
Really, we've got some releases done underneath that.
I like I like that colorful graph. It's
very pretty.
Yep. We also have light mode, if you
prefer that. I don't know if that's maybe
a bit bright. Harsh. Yeah.
Depending on my mood, how I switch between
them.
Okay. So we do have release information. The
first sale that we have here is just
kind of a
look at the cadence of all the projects.
I don't know if there's actually any use
in this one yet. I haven't found one.
But when we break that down by repository,
I think it gets a little bit more
interesting.
I also think, like, when is the first
release? When did you start doing release hygiene?
And having had a project running
effectively
for three
for two months, maybe
maybe about just over two months before the
first release tag there.
And then does that mean there was three
at that point?
Yes. So that means in January 2017, you
had three releases.
That's
not January. It's February, isn't it? Well, this
window is at the February, which means the
releases happened a month earlier.
Oh, okay. So if we break this down,
like, we are looking at monthly.
But if we break that down to weekly,
you'll actually see the weekly Alright. It varies.
Plus.
Yeah. So we've got one in
the January 5. So the January
2017,
another So it's very soon after the after
the repo was done. Yeah.
If you want, we can do it daily,
but probably not as useful. One of the
things that the source d team found when
they were looking at it, and they didn't
have any context was why you're releasing multiple
times per day.
And,
basically, it's because the releases generate the artifacts.
And if you merge a PR,
you want to have that available for people
to test or to update a composed file
or to just do an update and drag
it in.
It's very cumbersome to to sort of get
someone to run through developer instructions just to
do a build to get an artifact to
run it.
And if it looks stable, if you're happy
with it, you cut a release. Then maybe
something else came in that you weren't expecting
that's also we might as well have that
as well.
And then you get a new artifact for
each one.
It's pretty much free storage on GitHub and
and Docker Hub.
Yeah.
I think something that's standing out to me
from from this graph here is that
you you mentioned that the the some sort
of migration or moving of of FASD, but
what we actually see is
there's 23 releases initially, and I'm gonna assume
those happened. Those tags were migrated from the
other repo maybe? I don't think they were.
I don't know why there's 23 tags. I
don't know what that is. Let's see if
we can. You could look into you could
look on GitHub and find out.
I mean, they all happen
very quickly. Like, how quickly?
Okay. Let's go to enter daily, and then
let's just zoom into this window.
So
seven
on the first day, 12/24/2019,
'4
on the twenty fifth.
It seems a bit high to me. I'm
not sure
what that is unless it's
Okay. So let's let's we're gonna look at
the deep dive dashboard, and that's what actually
less the individual releases as a table. So
let's just take a look at the FaaS
d repo the FaaS d repo there.
There is actually 47 releases of this, and
I'm now
struggling to think why
there'd be so many.
I wonder if this was when
we got some odd untagged release then. I'm
not sure what that is.
Well, my scatter plot is
broken. I
do wonder if I was sort of fighting
Travis
for a little bit. I don't know. No.
They do seem to have assets on from
quite early on. Don't know why.
Oh, you had too much Christmas pudding.
So this is a scatter plot visualization of
the existing above. I use scatter plots as
a way to kind of identify outliers.
We can see
FaaS CLI have quite a heavy release.
I don't know what happened here, but twelve
and thirteen releases across two months.
And
OpenFaaS cloud is obviously think the I was
getting a lot of interest
from the community. It was it needed to
be built from scratch and every command that
was added.
It was useful to have a release and
get it tested again to the hands of
users properly.
And my I see it's supposed to be
a histogram, which looks like it's rather broken.
So hopefully, we can see that on the
deep dive dashboard.
So the last thing I want to show
off in the overview one
is we can have the ability to break
down by looking at the type of code
that was added.
No surprise that, you know, Go is pretty
prominent across these repositories.
There'll be go. There'll be bash. There's a
YAML mark there'll be a lot of markdown.
See, that's almost like the second biggest.
And it's bit of JavaScript and HTML in
there as well.
No extensions.
I'm not sure of it. Parsing them?
Yep. We got shell scripts. We got YAML.
In fact, if we just zoom in to
this bottom oh, there's still lot going on
here. Okay.
PEMs,
r,
lock fail. Okay.
We got a fair amount of stuff going
on here.
This is just breaking it up by repository
because all of the repos are primarily go.
I don't think we're gonna get anything particularly
useful from this, so we'll skip over.
But the last bit on the overview, I
I to call this I've
got to just interrupt someone
on OpenFaaS Slack has said spikes in October.
Was it Hacktoberfest?
Ah.
Yes. It would have been because we participate
quite actively in that.
Yeah. And those will be merged ones. Right?
Because the spam ones wouldn't have made it
into the guest room.
Yes. We I only analyzed the the master
branch. Yeah. Not not the GitHub API,
which is better.
Because I remember I asked I was asking
you earlier because I was wondering if you're
like well, now that you're live on a
webinar, give me admin access to your GitHub
organizations so we can import the data.
And, unfortunately, you would get cloning, which is
I think is a nice way of doing
it.
Yeah. It works well, I think. And you
can do it for any public repository. One
of the other use cases I've I've been
trying to use get series for is making
decisions on when to adopt different what what
which service mesh should you use? Well, you
you can import all of them and see
which ones are more vibrant, has the most
contributors, and is actively or has a stable
release cadence. You know, those those are the
things that we probably
don't spend enough time investigating when we adopt.
Yeah.
Yeah. So this last bit is the how
to get help. So are there any esoteric
programming languages used across any of the OpenFaaS
reports?
Guess the last
The only thing that comes to mind is
probably, like, the r file, which is one
of the samples that from the community.
And for some weird reason, I don't see
r. Let's try do we have Python? When
you do r.
It was. Yeah. I'm not sure why it's
not showing up on my lovely table here.
Do you know what names are gonna show
up on the Python?
There's examples
potential examples
for that. Let me handle that p y.
I'm sorry. Contributor. Who who would rate the
Python on the OpenFaaS projects?
Me, probably. You. Lucas?
No. It's it looks like it's a 26
commits of Python fails you have on your
your Remember that author email is incorrect. We
need to look at the author name.
I see. Probably some from Ivana probably and
Martin.
You are correct.
Yeah. It's a bit better actually. Let's
so
yeah. You're still the top three. I love
your different names across these.
The Alex one is surprising. I'm not sure
what that one was. That might have been
at the beginning when I when I didn't
know how to get get properly.
And there's a little bit when I worked
at VMware.
If you look at dot go, you should
see some Alex Alice brackets
OpenFaaS
limited.
Yep. Some AlexLS.
I'm surprised we've not got any
AlexLS VMware, but maybe that's because
There was a Python. It went in the
top five.
Yeah.
And if we take a look at How
about MDs?
I don't
Alright. MD. Yeah. Let's take a look at
markdown. Let's look at our managing directors.
Yeah. Okay.
So he's writing a lot of docs when
I was at VMware.
John's been active. Luke's is really active as
well.
Cool.
Yeah. So this is I I think this
table is good if especially if you join
an organization and they're analyzing their commits this
way and you wanna know who to go
speak to to get help with Python or
Ruby or Rust, like, I think this is
a a nice way to do it. But
we don't have a great spread of stuff
here. Is that some SQL? But I I
do actually like that too. I like the
approach of
let's
let's see who's been touching what files, and
then we can tap them up for support,
throw it over the wall to them. You're
gonna love to deep dive dashboard then. There's
a time series based code owners analysis
as well. So
so what's written in c? I'm curious. There's
a fair number of c commits here. Probably
vended
c go code
rather than anything that's actually
used.
We don't even build in c code. I
bet that there's some
vendor stuff that's got
craft in it.
Okay. Where's your repository at? Also a sample
project
of a c function.
Alright. We
said FAST. Right? Let me take a look
at that first. Oh, yeah.
So this is our commit count.
That's a relatively new project. I can't remember
what we were trying to identify with this.
Okay.
So
Yeah. There's a release. That's what we wanted
to because we had that high number of
release. Yeah. I just had a look on
GitHub.
I'm not really sure. It just it's like
that
maybe that was the best way to share
binaries for people at the time
because working on a Mac, you don't get
you couldn't build it on a Mac at
the time or in the tests because
it needed WeaveNet,
which is
Linux only.
This is one of the weirdest projects in
OpenFaaS because you can only work on it
on Linux, and it's only for Linux. You
can't run it on a Mac and connect
to a Docker instance. So meant to be,
like, self contained
serverless.
Drop it on a VM stateless.
Doesn't scale beyond one node. You can do,
like, a RAID style if you want.
You know, close the box, never open it
again type of thing.
Alright. Okay.
Well, based on that, I just I've just
switched over to FaaS ninety's unless you wanna
pick something else just to kinda run through
this dashboard. Go for it. FaaS ninety's done.
So this is the commit
graph again. Only this time, we're breaking it
down to look at the insertions and deletions.
So we can see the blue lines
are lot of insertions. So this is obviously
early days where we're writing lots and lots
of code.
There's obviously some sort of large
change was made here. So the purple is
our deletions.
Even Likely.
Well, I think that would choose an insertion
because you wouldn't be modifying any code.
Deletion, didn't you say?
Yeah. But when the insertions and deletions are
both tracking each other like this, it generally
means files are modified.
Because the way, obviously, if you think of
a get patch, there's a insertion and a
deletion. Upstream
vendor dependency was changed, but not the name
didn't change.
Don't know. Yeah.
At some point, what you you what you
need is maybe to
to zoom in on that and see the
raw data.
I think we have access to the commits
further down, if I remember correctly.
Yeah. The other thing that stands out here
is we have test two double peaks, one
of a massive deletion followed by
two sizable insertions.
This
was
when? March
2019,
just over a year ago.
Well, it could delete it. I think to
make sense of this, we need to exclude
on the rejects
anything with the word vendor in it.
Otherwise, it's just
too it's not particularly representative.
Alright. Tell you what, let's jump down to
the the directory breakdown. So first, we'll take
a look at
March 2018 and then March 2019, and we'll
see what we can see was modified. So
we'll come back to the things we're skipping,
but
if we take a look,
the directory is here. So March
was indeed a massive
not massive. The sizable vendor change. So the
JSON iterator
seems to have been brought in
and,
yeah, a few others.
Got some stuff in the helm chart as
well.
Again, vendor, vendor, vendor, vendor.
We need to we probably need to have
a look at
excluding that. It's a prefix of vendor. Just
have another look. So there should be some
interesting information in here.
That is a bit wood for the trees.
Alright. So what do we not want to
see?
Filter
f n
r. And you know what? I purely
I'm not that familiar with the reject syntax,
but we're gonna try and work this out.
You could do the contains because we don't
have any files that say vendor that
at the end. I know vendors always at
the beginning.
So I think if we do this,
we want
to filter on not vendor.
I got very lucky that that worked.
Well, let's look at the graph first.
Yeah. So all the vendor changes I did
get lucky there. So I'm seeing a YAML
folder
peaking.
Again, that is something that we generate from
the chart now. We used to maintain it
separately. It's now generated from the chart.
Lucas made a change that is really useful
because we used to maintain both. Now we
have the chance to source the truth. That
spits out YAML for x eight six, for
ARM 64.
Okay. Oh, yeah. You can see the chart
as well popping in here.
We got the documentation.
Good.
And, of course, it's a gold project. I
I see something I see all the time
with gold projects is all the code lives
in the root directory for so long, and
then
they start to migrate and move it into
subdirectories and packages and stuff like that. OpenFaaS
seems or FastNetis seems
to kinda follow that same pattern. Yeah. Because
we merged in another controller called the operator
that worked in CRDs into this code base
right at the end, probably that last peak
or the one before it, and then added
more folders.
So more code, more folders,
potentially why there's a dip.
Actually, a server folder coming in.
The package server maybe.
The docket have directory changing a little bit.
Keeping our templates up to date for issues
and PRs.
Yeah. Got the connector came in. And so
what we started to do, use the FastNet
as repo for
the charts for other other
things that we wanted.
So they weren't all in separate repos all
in one. So that's connected. I've acted that.
The MQTT connector, that's got its chart in
there. Chrome connector.
Yeah. You can see all that kinda popping
up. End to end tests and then all
the package directory says you've
Yeah. Broken stuff down. Nice.
Okay. Well, this new. That looks interesting as
well.
Underneath it.
Yeah. So this tracks
new fails added to the repository
and looks at their extension.
So that really good way of seeing migrations
from JavaScript
to TypeScript or from, you know, CSS to
SaaS, but I don't think we're gonna see
anything
prominent across these repositories.
Again, just with it being primarily go.
No. And as I say, if we
if we drop the vendor cache out of
some of the repos, you just see a
massive drop.
Let's jump back up here. So
that's our commit one. So something else we
tried to do with get series
is try to make easy for newcomers to
see what the commit patterns are within a
repository by analyzing the size of those commits.
So what we have here is the ninetieth
quantile, the fiftieth quantile, and the first quantile.
So it's very rare that you'd see a
commit larger than this or smaller than this.
So let's just ignore the one because it's
not very interesting. This is also not normalized.
Is it? This is including vendor?
Yeah. Because this happens on a commit level,
we don't actually understand the contents of the
commit when we build these queries. So
yeah. So I guess that's not gonna be
as
yeah. Maybe the numbers aren't as great because
of those vendor changes.
Mhmm. Mhmm. But we can see roughly the
effective quantile is you modify two files and
add 11 lines of code. Anywhere from there
up to a 55 lines of code across
12 files. So I think what you're seeing
here is small type of faxes
up to vendor changes. So quite a a
broad spectrum of what normal would be there,
I guess. Yeah.
Alright. What else do we have to send?
We get we we're sort of running running
out of time now. I wondered what you
referred to graphs that look like.
Yes.
At some time at some point, you might
wanna think about, like, a word map based
upon the commit message.
If you sort of break it down, I
don't know if you could do that in
influx or maybe do it separately.
Get, like, a like, how many times have
you been using the word add, update,
bug,
and that sort of thing. That would be
interesting.
Yeah. There are definitely things we can do
there. We can't do the word map or
the tokenization on influx, but I could do
that as a preprocessor and Yeah. Yeah. Those
aggregate looking at earlier. I mean, you wouldn't
necessarily be able to put it in as
a as an array, but it could be
another table
that you put in
that's sort of a bit more denormalized.
Doesn't necessarily correlate back.
Yeah. Well, you actually have the ability on
this table to filter by commits
Yeah. Such for Kubernetes. These
are the commits that mentioned Kubernetes
as a raw string.
The other thing is we have here before
we move on are just the ability to
break down
by directory, which is more of a
a backup plan. If you had conventional
or semantic commits, there's also the ability to
break down by whether there's a feature, a
bug fix, etcetera, which is what this graph
shows.
So
the commits aren't in that format, so we
can't get too much.
Alright. Let's
jump through the last two and then
we can let you get back up. Again.
You could actually find
what's the perfect spot looking for the word
closes.
We normally use that keyword.
That's a good point. Yeah. We could do
that.
So this is the year on year analysis.
So for this to work, I need to
do twenty nineteen o one zero one and
twenty twenty o one.
And we can see this
these are the
commit counts across year after year
by month.
As I said, this dashboard's not that interesting
yet. The author breakdown is slightly more interesting.
So we can see Three different Alex's versions
of me in there somehow.
Yeah. So your biggest commit year was 2017.
And this purple line here, at least towards
the end was really, really strong. Medal of
the year,
you got 2019
was a really strong year, but the end
of 2019 being a bit calmer. The other
thing is we've got a bit
we've got another organization
that has commits in it as well that
isn't represented here.
OpenFaaS
incubator.
I see Lucas has got quite a few
commits now. I'd expect to see that too.
Yeah. His twenty twenty years started up really
strong. I'm sure he's probably got a a
strong finish on 2019 somewhere. If we could
maybe just do that and find that.
I am cautious of time.
And these work on a semantic commits. I
could modify these to work on a directory
for projects that don't have semantic commits.
Mhmm. Let's move on to the wall of
shame.
Now this one is a little bit
memory and CPU intensive. So I'm gonna try
and run it across everything.
And if it takes too long, we'll drop
it down to maybe two years.
You can see that timer is going up.
So this first does a leaderboard for the
most commits within a given window. So the
most commits in any given month, and no
surprise, you're top in the charts.
And so your your month with the most
commits ever
was
October 2017 with a 82
commits.
Yeah. 2017 is obviously a really busy year
for you working on at
least, like, you joined VMware in 2018.
Yeah.
Yeah. There we go again.
Maybe I did ask too much of this
machine.
I got a 19 and then 18 and
a 19 somehow mixed up there.
We're sorry? Ordering to something right. Alright. So
this is ordered by a number of commits
and then the month from which those commits
will occur. So Okay.
Now down here, what we have are
not so great for open source, but for
private repositories, quite useful. It will show you,
if you join this organization, how many days
will you commit code to master, so measurable
code on a monthly basis.
For open source projects, even analyzing influx DB
itself, these numbers are extremely skewed.
So, yeah, not that useful for open source,
but you can see that
in fact, let's just start by day.
Oh,
early on and then
yeah, so the peak number of commits per
day
was are in 2018.
And I guess these numbers are dropping because
of, you know, COVID maybe gone over the
last few months. I don't know if you
noticed a drop in contributions over the last
There's not a lot of people that contribute
in on a regular basis. The fees for
sporadic or they they're taking a bit longer.
We've also got
the n x project,
catch up in arcade, where some people are
making commits there instead. And as I said,
there's another reap there's another org called OpenFaaS
incubator,
and some commits end up going there instead
of into
OpenFaaS.
Ah, okay. Cool. But, yeah, COVID isn't great
for sponsorship
or
consulting work or get up commence. It's
yeah. All for your health for that matter.
And we'll finish up with the
last graph, which again for open source is
really
doesn't provide a lot of value. But for
private organizations, being able to understand and classify
what a week of work looks like, and
then how long someone has been with the
time off.
So currently, the query will look for more
than
four days of commits and any given seven
day period,
and that counts as a working week. And
it would seem,
based on the numbers we've seen above in
the leaderboard, you know, towards the end of
twenty seventeen, you worked on us eighteen weeks
straight.
Mhmm. A of commits.
At the end of twenty nineteen, you went
for twelve
weeks without
with committing something every day. Now, of course,
you're merging a lot of these branches and
this does work on
or maybe this is alter name. I'm not
sure.
I would actually yeah. It looks like it
is. So was there anything large that happened
at the end of twenty nineteen that you
were just
putting in a lot of work there?
Yeah. I think so.
I think towards the end of twenty nineteen,
I was basically
independent
then
and trying to hold up going from a
team of four full time people to
me.
I was trying to sort of
take the load on, I think.
So
if you look at if you look at
my GitHub
bathroom tiles,
you'll see
a similar effect. And I think
this year, there's some days because I've done
more client work now.
You'll see some gaps in the tiles.
If you look at the year before, you
probably see that it's quite dense.
See, from about February,
we start to see some gaps. But I
think, basically, twenty
twenty twenty nineteen, if you can click on
it, I think it will update.
Let's see if it does or not. What
will update? Sorry? 2019.
Does that update you?
I don't think so. Yes. It does. You
see, basically,
other than a little bit of time in
March,
pretty much working solid every day on on
open source.
So
2020,
a bit more client work. I was explaining
this in a in a Twitter thread. So
I saw one one of these guys has
got himself up to $10 a month in
sponsorships.
I think it's a bit of a luxury,
really. I mean, if you can get to
that point, it's
similar to a low paid job in IT,
like an intern or junior salary
in dollars.
It was certainly enough to kinda keep things
afloat and concentrate on the project. For me,
you know, you can see those gaps in
having sort sort of done the consulting work
to pay the bills, and I'm developing a
business there because,
you know, in the long in the long
run without
sufficient contributors,
without full time staff, it is very difficult
to keep open source project going. I mean,
if you don't have a job, you don't
have anybody paying you to do that. It's
the option there aren't many options for you.
And it's just how much can you afford
to give.
Yeah.
Alright. Well,
that was really interesting from my point of
view. I hope this the stats gonna give
you a little bit of insight into your
own project that maybe you didn't have before.
And and, you know, it was really good
of you to join me today. So thank
you, Alex. Yeah. I've sent a few screenshots
out. We have to take a look at
some of the more interesting graphs.
Looking forward to see how this project develops.
And, actually, I wonder
if at some point you you might sort
of host the data that you've ingested somewhere
in a read only mode. You can have
a look at it or
maybe do an export. Maybe you could write
an OpenFaaS function to export something from the
Prometheus data and run a scratch. Nice.
Yeah. Our our kind of cloud team are
are working on public buckets that people can
consume and build their own dashboards on data.
And we're actually working on the ability to
embed those graphs and sales into other
websites
and projects as well. So, I mean, hopefully,
over time, as the project kind of evolves,
we can get more of that data available
to people to play with without doing the
the hard bit of importing approach. I guess,
finally, the question I'd have for you is,
is it practical that somebody could go to
the the repo that you have here and
get to what we saw today? Or do
they need is this things I need to
know? I noticed there wasn't a read me
file, for instance. So what
are you planning to add one?
Yeah. Of course. So the read me,
as this was conference driven development, I just
had to make it work so I could
record my talk. Yeah. You know, there's a
lot of things that are missing. There's no
test, which I'd love to add to the
project. There was no documentation.
But in order to get to where I
should in order to have to grasp that
I should be, all you need to do
is run get series analysis, run the telegraph
config, and everything works. Apply that package or
dot YAML. But it takes, five minutes to
get up and running.
Well, you've got instructions for that,
do you publish them or retweet it if
anyone's listening or watching this later on and
wants to try it with their project. I'm
sure there's loads of people that would love
to sort of dig through their repos.
Yeah. Well, I promise to you and anyone
watching that I will have a read me
added to the project today.
Today.
I will do it today. Very cool. For
sure. Excellent.
Alright. Alright. Well, thank you for joining me
again, Alex. I was